le muséum d'histoire naturelle possède
une belle collection de poissons
naturalisés qui datent pour certains du
de la moitié du 19e siècle et vous voyez
qu'au 19e siècle
nous avions les poissons été verni
tandis qu'aujourd'hui on les naturalise
et on les remet en couleurs de façon à
ce qu'ils soient le plus proche possible
de la réalité quand ils sont vivants et
ses poissons ou sont amenés par soit par
des pêcheurs qui trouvent des raretés
qui les amène au muséum soit par
l'aquarium de la réunion ou encore par
l'ifremer qui nous a fait don d'une
collection de poissons en alcool mais
aussi par en participant à des campagnes
océanographiques comme ce fut le cas en
2009 et en 2010 on a participé à la
planète revisitée une vaste campagne
d'inventaire de la biodiversité qui
s'est fait dans le sud de madagascar ou
dans l'ouest de madagascar 1 du côté de
nocibé est organisée par le muséum de
paris ce qui nous a permis de ramener
des poissons de grande profondeur chose
qui est très difficile à voir si on
participe pas à ce type de campagne
non